Richtig, Chad. Auf den Mount Everest.
Tangle.
Pog Subscription.
Massive High IQ Sub.
Du bist schon in der Gruppe.
Kann das sein?
Die Gruppe gibt es erst seit 1 Minute 16.
Alois Motke.
Du hast Early Access Group gehabt.
7LQRS.
Weitere High IQ Sub.
Biggest Brains hier wieder.
Schon was von Bann gehört.
JavaScript.
Ja.
Ich glaube, wir haben sogar ein Video offen von Fireship, was wir gucken wollten.
Oder?
Wir haben das geguckt sogar am Sonntag.
Ich weiß nicht.
Natürlich.
Wie sich das für jede gute Gruppe gehört, Leute.
5 Leute noch.
Dann mache ich dicht.
Müsst ihr jetzt.
Gönnt euch jetzt.
Ich habe meine Gönnier.
Kaminwoche.
Es gibt so viele deflische Sprüche dafür.
Gönnt euch die Gruppe.
Dann mache ich aber wirklich nicht.
Der Link.
Den gibt es erst nach Prime Sub.
Ansonsten den Discord.
Wobei Discord habe ich teilweise in letzter Zeit das Gefühl,
dass es mehr Selbsthilfe Gruppe als Technik Technik Gelaber noch.
Manche Leute haben ja echt.
Probleme.
Denke ich mir immer so.
Hey, wenn ich wirklich richtige Probleme habe.
Gehe ich dann in den Discord von Max und und hoffe, da ist irgendjemand da.
Der versteht, was ich für Probleme habe.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß.
Macht ihr nur, wenn es euch hilft, ist gut.
Ich habe meine Bedenken, ob das einem wirklich hilft.
Potato Bob 23 Pog Subscription.
Ja, Next Level.
Ich habe mehrere.
Gruppen, weil ihr wisst, wie das ist.
Eine Gruppe alleine tut ja nicht.
Man muss erst in eine Gruppe und dann gibt es noch eine Premium und auch eine VIP Gruppe.
Und du musst dann upgraden von der Premium, also von der normalen Gruppe und in die Premium Gruppe.
Können aber nur immer fünf Leute rein und nur einer davon kann upgraden auf die VIP Gruppe.
Das wird auch so, dass da muss das Business Business muss richtig laufen.
Ich habe noch übrigens noch nie verstanden bei diesen Videos.
Das oder beziehungsweise bei diesen bei diesen.
Werbespot sind ja im Endeffekt und aber und aber auch Videos von diesen ganzen Coaches.
Dass da immer noch so viele drauf reinfallen.
Hör auf, hör auf.
Tier 2 Subscription.
Dazu kann ich ja sagen, dass es highest IQ.
Das ist ja nicht plus zehn.
Das ist ja schon plus drei.
30 für alle.
Nice.
Ja, die Mods, die Mods kümmern sich drum.
Ja, ich verstehe nicht, warum da immer noch Leute drauf reinfallen.
So bei diesem ganzen.
Wir, wir erklären da, wie du reich wirst, weil ganz im Ernst, welches.
Also eine Sache, die ich mich schon seit Ewigkeiten frage, ist, welches Interesse hat jemand, der einen super krassen Trick wie ihr reich wird gefunden hat, diesen Trick der ganzen Welt zu erklären.
Das konnte mir noch nie jemand schlüssig erklären.
Und dann kommt am Ende.
Kommt am Ende raus.
Es ist einfach alles Scam.
Wer hätte das nur ahnen können?
Leute, morgen früh muss ich wieder aufstehen.
Sieben Uhr muss ich nach Frankfurt fahren.
Ist gar kein Bock.
Trainge muss ich dann machen.
Mit der deutschen Bahn.
Ja, keck, keck Business.
Ich muss.
Morgen muss ich Monka, Monka DB machen.
Hatten wir da nicht.
Doch hatten wir morgen.
Leute, ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Dann ist morgen auf der Arbeit so eine komische Veranstaltung.
Die fängt irgendwie morgens an und geht irgendwie bis mittags.
Keine Ahnung.
Gucken.
Vielleicht kann ich.
Vielleicht kann ich schon wieder 16 Uhr abhauen.
Weil überhaupt kein Bock.
Business.
Letztens auf der Arbeit.
Ihr wisst ja, ihr kennt ja, ihr kennt ja meine Karriere.
Ambitionen.
Ja, also Leute.
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin.
Ich will unbedingt super, super krass Karriere machen und kleine dafür jeden Tag 24 7 und
Hassel mir einen ab.
So habt ihr mich kennengelernt.
Die letzten 12 Jahre habe ich 13 Jahre schon.
Habe ich recht?
Ihr kennt sicherlich keinen krasseren Karriere kleiner wie mich.
Zumindest wird sie witzigerweise.
Es gibt.
Es gibt so eine Veranstaltung, nennt sich.
Glaube ich.
Abteilungsleiter, Sprechstunde oder sowas.
Irgendwie so heißt das bei uns auf der Arbeit.
Und das ist irgendwie einmal im halben Jahr.
Und da.
Da kam letztens eine Mail.
Okay, die Anmeldungen sind jetzt offen.
Ich dachte mir so.
Ja, schön für euch, wenn die Anmeldungen offen sind.
Ich gehe da eh nicht hin.
Kein Bock drauf.
Nach ein paar.
Nach ein paar Tagen.
Also irgendwie so.
Nachdem noch zwei.
Nachdem irgendwie die Anmeldung noch zwei Tage offen war.
Habe ich mal in die Anmeldeliste geguckt.
Was war?
Übrigens Leute.
Also muss man dazu sagen.
Ja, das ist eine Veranstaltung.
Und wir haben Outlook Teams, 50 verschiedene Wikis, Zeiterfassungssysteme, Schulungssysteme, Planungssysteme.
So und dreimal dürft ihr raten.
Jetzt.
Mit welchem Tool wird die Teilnehmerliste gepflegt für diese Veranstaltung?
Was meint ihr?
Man hat 30 Tools zur Auswahl, die das alles richtig gut können.
Was?
Ich meine Excel.
Korrekt.
Excel.
Aber Moment.
Moment.
Excel alleine ist es noch nicht.
Noch nicht Excel.
Nicht Excel alleine.
Ihr habt.
Die eigentliche Kombination ist.
Excel auf einem Windows Share.
Excel auf dem Sammler Laufwerk.
Irgendwo.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit den Leuten los ist.
Weißt du?
Hast 30 Milliarden Tools, die alle das gut können, sogar gleichzeitig editierbar und
alles.
Ist Excel irgendwo abgelegt auf Windows?
Na gut.
Wie dem auch sei.
Hat sich seit Jahren bewährt.
Mittlerweile geht das, glaube ich, sogar ganz gut.
Collaboration Excel auf Windows Share.
Aber.
Ich habe dann zumindest mal so just for fun.
Es kam dann nochmal.
Es kam dann nochmal eine Message in Teams.
Leute, die Abteilungsleiter Sprechstunde.
Nun, das war wahrscheinlich letzte Woche Mittwoch oder so was.
Nur noch zwei Tage Zeit, sich anzumelden.
Okay.
Leute, jetzt ratet mal.
Ratet mal.
Abteilung.
Also Abteilungsleiter Sprechstunde heißt.
Alle fragen mich, wie viel, wie viel es da gibt.
Acht oder so.
Abteilungsleiter setzen sich mit Fragen und Themen so der Leute, die sich dort anmelden,
auseinander und kann ein bisschen schwätzen und was auch immer.
Also es gibt insgesamt 40 Plätze, 45, 45 Plätze.
45 Leute können sich darin eintragen und teilnehmen.
Was meint ihr?
Wie viele Leute?
Wie viele Leute haben sich angemeldet auf diese 45 Plätze?
Zwei Tage vor Anmeldeschluss.
Okay, Leute, ihr seid gar nicht schlecht.
Ihr seid gar nicht schlecht.
Ihr seid nicht schlecht.
Die richtige Antwort habe ich noch nicht gelesen.
Aber ihr seid wirklich.
Es bleibt ja nicht mehr viel übrig.
Nee, nee, es fehlt ja nicht mehr viel.
Okay, ich sage es euch.
Sechs.
Das hat nämlich noch keiner gesagt.
Sechs Leute.
Von 45.
Da sieht man schon mal, wie extrem, wie viel, extrem viel Bock die Leute darauf haben.
So, haben sich sechs Leute angemeldet.
Bam Bam Bude.
Danke für den Sub.
Ich hoffe, ich habe nichts gesehen.
Potato Bob.
Sicherlich schon.
Modges haben dir den Link zur Gruppe geschickt, hoffe ich.
So, also es haben sich.
Es haben sich sechs Leute angemeldet.
Und jetzt?
Was schwätzen die?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Du hast das.
Du hast.
Du hast das falsch verstanden.
Dort gehen alle Abteilungsleiter hin, die wir haben.
Das sind, glaube ich, acht Stück.
Und es können sich 45 Leute anmelden und mit allen Abteilungsleiter reden oder Themen
anbringen, die sie gerne besprechen wollen.
So in kleineren Gruppchen mit dem jeweiligen Abteilungsleiter.
So ist das gedacht.
Es sind 45, nicht 45 Leute, 45 Plätze frei, wo man sich anmelden kann.
So, zumindest nachdem wir das geklärt haben, dass sich ganze sechs Leute von 45 angemeldet
haben.
Dachte ich mir so, oh nee, nee, nee, ich hab keinen Bock.
Und dann schreibt mich ein Kollege an in Teams, hat gemeint Max, weißt du was?
Ich hab, ich hab einen Tipp für dich.
Da habe ich schon gedacht, okay, was kommt jetzt?
Und da meinte er so Max, falls du nicht mitgekriegt hast.
In zwei Tagen ist Anmeldeschluss für die.
Für die, für die, für diese halbjährige halbjährige Abteilungsleiter Sprechstunde.
Geh da doch mal hin.
Das ist sicherlich richtig gut für deine Karriere.
Dann musste ich ihm erst mal erklären, was für ein krasser Karriere Kreisel Kreisel
Grinder ich bin.
Muss ich mir erst mal erklären, dass ich wenig Interesse an irgendwelchen weiterführenden
Personal und sonst was verantwortungsvollen Aufgaben habe.
Ich will einfach.
Ich will einfach Cloud und Linux Zeug machen, bis ich in Rente gehe.
Wobei, bis ich in Rente gehe nicht.
Das ist Blödsinn.
Rente gehe ich ja wahrscheinlich mit was weiß ich, wann alles Renten halt ist, bis
ich keinen Bock mehr habe.
Bis ich keinen Bock mehr habe, will ich das machen.
Ja, so und jetzt.
Und jetzt kommt.
Jetzt kommt der Plot Twist bei der ganzen Sache.
Fünf Minuten später.
Also ich habe ihm dann erst mal erklärt.
So eine Karriere.
Karriere Grind.
Geht mir nicht auf die Nerven.
Will ich nicht.
So und jetzt.
Und jetzt kommt er.
Jetzt kommt der Plot Twist.
Fünf Minuten später, nachdem ich dem erklärt habe, warum ich da keinen Bock drauf habe.
Das mit dem Fiat darf ich nicht überlesen.
Da wollte ich tatsächlich was zu sagen.
So fünf Minuten, nachdem ich ihm erklärt habe, dass ich keinen Bock auf sowas habe,
weil ich keinen Bock auf Karriere Grind habe, kam der Kollege, mit dem ich von der alten
Arbeit zur neuen Arbeit gewechselt bin.
Also den ich schon jahrelang kenne.
Und meint Max.
Sag mal.
Eigentlich habe ich ja keinen Bock, aber.
Also.
Was hältst du davon, wenn wir auf diese Abteilungsleiter Sprechstunde gehen?
Ich habe keine Lust darauf.
Alter hör auf.
Ja, aber er wird sich das ja mal angucken.
Aber allein will er da auch nicht hin.
Weil was soll er da erzählen?
Also okay.
Meinetwegen, weil du es bist.
Und jetzt gehe ich morgen auf die Abteilungsleiter Sprechstunde.
Das wird was.
Da habe ich überhaupt.
Ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Mann, wehe, der kommt morgen nicht.
Wenn der morgen nicht da ist.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen Fuß gebrochen oder so.
Dann gehe ich da auch nicht hin.
Ich habe so keinen Bock, Leute.
Ich mag solche Veranstaltungen halt null.
Na gut.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, wie es läuft.
So.
Ich wollte.
Ich wollte was.
Ich wollte zu meinem Auto was erzählen.
Kurz hier.
Wie ist eigentlich dein Fazit zu deinem Elektro Fiat?
Alles gut.
Ja.
Was willst du wissen?
Ich weiß.
Weiß gar nicht, was ich dir großartig erzählen soll.
Ja.
Ich bin heute wieder zum Ausflug Kreisel Kreislaufen gefahren mit dem Auto.
Umweltfreundlich, so wie sich das gehört.
Warum scrollt der Chat darunter?
Ach so, weil er auf Fiat stand.
Ja.
Was willst du?
Was willst du wissen?
Was?
Ist dieser Sesam?
Sesam Sam?
Also ich meine, ich habe ja schon öfters was darüber erzählt.
Es ist kein Vergleich zu meinem Auto davor.
Ich meine, ich hatte für alle, die es immer noch nicht wissen.
Ich hatte das beste Auto überhaupt ever jemals jemals gemacht davor.
Und zwar einen grünen 2001er.
GG.
GG Eats.
Ja.
Das.
Das ist das Auto.
Da sind die Grills am Start.
So.
Das hatte ich davor.
Und das ist kein Vergleich dazu.
Ich meine, das Auto ist von 2001.
Ihr könnt euch überlegen.
Das Ding hatte nix.
Das hatte keine Displays für irgendwas.
Das hatte.
Anna.
Das hatte noch.
Das hatte alles analoge Geschwindigkeitsanzeigen, Tankfüllungsanzeigen und alles Mögliche.
War da oldschool.
Ich bin mir jetzt nach.
Ich habe das Auto zwar schon ein Jahr nicht mehr.
Ich bin mir nicht mal sicher, ob das überhaupt schon irgendwie sowas wie Servolenkung hat
oder so.
Ich glaube schon.
Ich bin mir da aber nicht sicher.
Liefs wie ein Uhrwerk.
Nee.
Also der hat jetzt zunehmend Probleme.
Deswegen habe ich mir ein neues Auto gekauft und weil ich Bock hatte, mal auf ein neues,
modernes Auto.
Zumindest insgesamt kann ich zum Fiat sagen.
Hat das Sesam Samen was geschrieben?
Ja.
Wollte wissen, ob das Auto irgendwelche Probleme macht.
So ist es natürlich.
Wenn alles funktioniert, macht er.
Lass mal überlegen.
Der hat so ein paar ganz kleine Eigenheiten, was wahrscheinlich jedes Auto haben wird.
Zum Beispiel diese Erkennung, wenn Leute auf die Fahrbahn springen.
Die ist gerade gerne mal morgens wird die deaktiviert, weil noch zu dunkel, zu neblig,
zu sonst was.
Aber es war auch okay, solange das Ding einfach nicht besser als das das einfach random bremst.
Ich hatte es übrigens einmal, dass das Auto random gebremst hat.
Aber ich kann mir.
Ich kann mir jetzt erklären, warum es das gemacht hat.
Einmal jetzt in einem Jahr.
Und da war da, da war das Auto hatte wahrscheinlich sogar irgendwo noch recht dort zu bremsen.
Und zwar ich bin da.
Ich bin auf dem Kreisverkehr zugefahren.
Nur wissen auf vor dem Kreisverkehr ist eine Ampel.
So und da stand ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das irgendwie noch richtig zusammen
geht.
Da stand eine Ampel.
Davor sind Häuser.
Da stand ein paar Tonnen rum.
Und da ist sind sind zwei zwei Kinder.
Ich glaube, einer war noch auf dem Roller und der andere ist gelaufen.
Sind auf die Ampel hinter den Tonnen raus auf die Ampel zugelaufen.
Halt relativ schnell.
Ich habe die gesehen.
Ich dachte mir auch die Ampel ist rot.
Die halten jetzt an.
Aber ein Fiat hat gemeint, so irgendwie kurz vorm Kreisverkehr und Ampel und und Leute
laufen zügig auf die Ampel zu.
Da hat er auf einmal wild angefangen zu piepsen und.
Da hat gar nicht gebremst.
Stimmt übrigens gar nicht.
Hat nicht gebremst.
Hat nur gepiepst.
Da waren gepiepst und ich hab dann gebremst oder ich hab dann langsamer langsamer gemacht.
Das war das einzige Mal, dass ich irgendwie Probleme mit den Assistenzsystemen hatte.
Was heißt wenn ich mal Probleme hatte.
Wahrscheinlich hat er recht gehabt.
Wahrscheinlich hätte ich, wenn die auf die Straße gesprungen wäre, gar nicht bremsen
können.
Aber die sah nicht so aus, als springen sie auf die Straße.
Die sah nur aus, als ist da.
Sind sie mit ihrem Roller halt gefahren.
Und dann sind die auf die Straße gesprungen.
Und dann werden sie halt an der Ampel angehalten.
Sind ja auch angehalten.
Also das ist das einzige, was da gewesen ist.
Welche Fiat führst du?
Fährst du denn?
Ich hab mir so ein Teil hier gekauft.
Fiat 500e.
Etwas günstiger gewesen.
Die Farbe ist aber nicht dabei.
Konfigurieren und kaufen.
Auf geht's.
Nein.
Fortfahren.
Alter sind die Dinger teuer mittlerweile.
Ich weiß nicht mal genau, was ich bezahlen soll.
Ich hab's euch aber erzählt.
Die hat noch so ein Konfigurator.
Ey, warum gibt's da...
Das ist gar nicht der E.
Ach, was auch immer.
Fiat Zeit ist echt bepeger.
Ist das nicht sogar das gleiche?
Tarex.
Ja.
Fiat 500e.
Ich dachte, du hättest gemietet oder geliest.
Ne.
Habe ich überlegt, ob ich das machen soll?
Habe ich wirklich überlegt?
Aber...
Ich bin dann...
Ich bin das Auto probefahren gegangen, hier in der Nähe.
Und da haben die mir erzählt, hier, Max, das ist ein Vorführauto, in dem du gerade drinnen hockst.
Ich glaube, Vorführautos dürfen ja irgendwie bloß sechs Monate in Benutzung sein.
So irgendwie, der ist in zwei Wochen.
Ist der quasi eh...
Läuft der eh ab?
Da hab ich gesagt, hier, und wie sieht's aus?
Und da haben die gesagt, jo.
Dann gibt's das natürlich auch billiger.
Und da haben wir ein bisschen rum...
Rumgemacht.
Was den Preis angeht.
Was letzten Preis haben wir gemacht.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, was ich bezahlt habe.
Ich hab's euch erzählt.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, ungefähr...
Ungefähr 25.000 Euro.
Irgendwie sowas.
Oder waren es nur 23.000?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Ich hab's verdrängt.
So, irgendwie was in dem Dreh.
35.000 Euro.
Normal neu kostet er, glaube ich, 38.000.
Aber nicht exakt in der Ausstattung.
Aber neu gekauft, das sieht keiner.
Zumal, es gab letztes Jahr auch noch...
Hab ich auch schon wieder vergessen, wie viel das war.
Hier noch Elektroauto-Prämie obendrauf.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, weißt du was?
Max, du hast dir vor über...
Oder sagen wir mal, vor...
20 Jahren...
20 Jahren zuletzt ein Auto geholt.
Kannst ja auch mal wieder ein Auto holen.
Ja, ne?
Ist nett, nett, nett von dem.
Ist es denn eigentlich nicht dein Ziel,
das Geld zu sparen, aufgrund der Ersparten
früher in Rente zu gehen?
Naja, mach ich doch.
Ich hab mein Stonks-ETF.
Ich geb für fast nix Geld aus.
Gar nicht, weil ich nicht Geld ausgeben will,
sondern weil es so wenig gibt,
wo ich es für...
ähm...
erstrebenswert oder angemessen halte,
Geld auszugeben.
Ich hab ein Haus geerbt.
Ich verdien 100k plus im Jahr.
Auf 5 Tage gerechnet.
Ich hab genug Geld auf...
Also...
Ich werde nicht bis zur Rente arbeiten.
Das kann ich dir sagen.
Das kann ich dir sicher sagen.
Garantiert nicht.
Ich mach das so lange, bis ich keinen Bock mehr hab.
Zur Not kann ich ja immer noch ein bisschen was
mit YouTube und Twitch verdienen,
wenn's hart auf hart kommen sollte.
Aber so aktuell...
Aktueller Finanzstatus sieht wirklich...
echt...
ganz, ganz brauchbar aus, ja.
Meine ETF-Stonks
haben auch richtig gestonkt
wieder. Die letzten...
Ich muss mal kurz gucken...
Scalable...
Was haben meine Stonks gemacht?
Ja!
Plus...
1214 Euro.
Richtig, richtig Stonks.
Letzten...
Letzten Monat?
Letzten eineinhalb Monate ging's richtig rauf.
Ich glaub in Scalable
kann man gar keine Prozent anzeigen lassen.
Kann das sein?
Oh Leute, ich glaub ich brauch auch bald
einen zweiten Account.
Bis wann ist Einlagensicherung?
Oder bis wann ist die Kohle sicher,
die man bei einem Anbieter hat?
50.000 oder 100.000?
200.000? Nee.
100.000?
Okay, dann ist noch ein bisschen hin.
Dann ist noch ein bisschen hin.
Bei Aktien gilt das glaub ich nicht.
Ja gut, das stimmt wohl, weil die Aktien gehören
ja.
Glaub ich.
Weil...
Mir gehören ja die Aktien, also ist im Prinzip ja egal,
ob dieser Traderladen pleite geht.
Ja.
Irgendwie so. Keine Ahnung.
Hahaha.
Ja, da geh ich auch nicht hin.
Ey, wenn der morgen nicht auftaucht, dann geh ich auch nicht hin.
Dann wird das andere
auch gewonnen.
Wir hatten's doch letztens hiervon.
Hermes!
Wie spricht man die eigentlich aus?
Das ist doch bestimmt französisch.
Hermes oder sowas heißt das doch bestimmt.
Hermes.
Hermes. Irgendwie sowas.
Wie spricht man das aus?
French
Pronunciation.
Hermes.
Ach ja, Hermes.
Removes
all Apple Watches and Bands from its...
Ach ja, das haben wir uns zuerst vor zwei Tagen angeguckt, Lul.
Da, moin!
Nee, ich hab's
sogar noch auf.
Wann denn Fiat flashen?
Naja, wir
getten dahin.
Ja.
Ich bin nämlich schon am überlegen, ob ich nicht
am eingebauten
Entertainment-System rumbasteln soll.
Gibt ja ein paar
Third-Party
Add-Ons schon.
Okay.
Heiner Brem.
Jetzt weiß ich Bescheid.
Woher weißt du das eigentlich?
Twitch-Chat hat es gesagt.
Läuft da ein Android drauf?
Ja, korrekt.
Android.
Oder wie im Heise-Forum die Leute schreiben würden,
ich habe einen Androiden im Auto.
Heise-Forum ist auch richtig krasse
Boomer-Party.
Ich habe einen Androiden im Auto.
Richtig
Pains-Champ, oder?
Richtig Pains-Champ.
Das sind die gleichen
Leute, die sagen,
Mini-Weich-Windhof.
Golem-Forum ist fast genauso.
Das sind die gleichen Leute.
Golem-Forum ist nicht ganz so viel los, wie im Heise-Forum.
Royal TS.
Ist Royal TS nicht
ein Hamburger?
Oh ja, wir haben auf der Arbeit auch Mobilexturn.
Wichtige Schrott-Software.
Kannst du mal den Unterschied
zwischen Node-Port und Cluster-IP erklären?
Ja.
Also,
das eine ist ein
Port auf dem jeweiligen Kubernetes
Node und das andere
ist Cluster-weit
gültige
Warum heißt das eigentlich IP?
Cluster-weit
gültige Endpoint ist
das richtige Wort, glaube ich.
Ist ja eine Mischung aus
also das geht ja um Services,
geht ja um Kubernetes-Services.
Endpoint ist im Kubernetes
Fachjargon, glaube ich, der korrekte
Begriff.
Also, warum auch immer das Cluster-IP heißt,
weiß ich nicht. Das ist eine eindeutige
IP für deinen Service, Cluster-weit
IP plus Port.
Also ein Endpoint
für den Service.
Und das ist halt Node-IP
plus einen Random-Port
von über 30.000.
Node-Port benutzt man
tatsächlich relativ selten.
Meistens Cluster-IP oder Loadbalancer,
aber hauptsächlich Cluster-IP.
Wie man Mod gewirrt,
als besonders
High-IQ auffallen.
Und dann müssen die
Modgis sagen, weil ich ernenne Leute nicht
direkt zum Mod.
Dann müssen die Modgis sagen, Leute,
wir brauchen ein bisschen Verstärkung
und die und die Leute sind mir im Chat
aufgefallen als Leute,
die wir für gute Modgis halten.
Ich entscheide das gar nicht.
Letztendlich, unterm Strich, am Ende
entscheide ich das immer noch, wer Mod wird.
Aber ich nehme einfach die Leute,
die die Modgis vorschlagen.
Die wissen es am besten.
Ich habe ja auch schon ein paar Leute selbst gemoddet,
von denen ich denke, okay,
die sind richtig schlau,
was bestimmte Themen angeht,
machen auch einen sehr umgänglichen Eindruck.
Die ersten paar Mods muss man sich ja,
muss ich mir ja noch selbst raussuchen,
aber seitdem verlasse ich mich eigentlich drauf,
was die Mods sagen und vorschlagen.
Aber ich muss sagen,
der Original-Cute-Mod fehlt mir
so ein bisschen hier.
Geht's noch irgendjemand so?
Der Sibaro müsste mal
ein bisschen öfters wieder da sein.
Leider ist von Sibaro
so wenig zu sehen.
Ich glaube, das liegt an zwei Sachen.
Entweder ist sein
Lehramtsstudium einfach so anstrengend,
wobei der auch bald mal fertig sein müsste.
Wie lang geht denn sowas?
Allzu lang kann das nicht mehr gehen.
Oder es hat doch geklappt
mit seinem Referendar-Grill,
was er da hatte
und
der ist anderweitig beschäftigt.
Sgt. Silver, danke für den Sub.
Wenn du drei Monate stellst,
dann hast du jetzt, glaube ich,
auch den Gold-Keks.
Wird das hier angezeigt?
Ne, Silber ist er noch.
Gold ist, glaube ich, ab sechs Monaten.
Also im Auto ist das ein Android.
Das ist bei Fiat.
Android Auto überall.
Und selbst drauf
kannst du mit, ach ne Moment,
das ist Android Auto Motiv, glaube ich,
weil Android Auto ist die Client-Anwendung dafür.
So rum ist das, glaube ich, korrekt.
Connecten kannst du dich
per CarPlay oder per Android Auto.
Sagt der TÜV eigentlich nichts,
wenn du Custom-Firmware auf dein Auto flashst.
Ich flashe keine Custom-Firmware auf mein Auto.
Was ich mir überlegt habe ist,
es gibt so ein paar Third-Party-Add-Ons.
Zum Beispiel, dass man eine eigene
Rückfahrkamera anschließen kann,
die dann aber auch halt eben
umgeschaltet wird,
wenn man rückwärts,
wenn man auf den Rückwärts-Button drückt.
Ich will nicht sagen, den Rückwärtsgang einlegen,
weil das macht man dort nicht.
Man drückt halt einen Knopf für Rückwärtsfahren.
Man kann dann auch noch mehrere
Video-Quellen anschließen
an das Display. Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Da habe ich mir überlegt, ob ich das
selbst modele.
Aber aktuell habe ich da keinen großartigen Bedarf für.
Deswegen, vielleicht schraube ich lieber nicht
an meinem Auto rum.
Link zum Git-Repo eingelassen.
Mit Hash von der Firmware.
Übrigens, Leute, wisst ihr, was wir
demnächst mal machen müssen?
OpenWrt.
Wir müssen das hier demnächst mal machen.
Oh!
Mein Auge! Ich sehe nichts!
Wir müssen das hier
beim nächsten Mal machen.
Wir müssen den Unify Access Point
flashen mit OpenWrt.
Ich habe hier noch
vier Unify Access Points, die aktuell im Schrank
vergammeln.
Und ich wollte es schon lange ausprobieren,
wie gut OpenWrt auf diesen Kisten ist.
Und dann habe ich mir was überlegt.
Willst du mir einen schicken?
Ne, will ich nicht.
Alles behalten.
Und dann habe ich mir nämlich überlegt,
ich habe...
Ich bin ja bei O2
mobile-mäßig und da kann man
bis zu sieben SIM-Karten kriegen.
Und ich habe, glaube ich, 40 GB im Monat.
Oder 20? Oder 40? Viel zu viel.
Und ich habe mir überlegt,
ob ich mir nicht ein
5G
WLAN-Router
ins Auto
lege.
Dann habe ich überall WLAN.
Ich meine, eigentlich ist es unsinnig,
dass ich alles, was ich im Auto dabei habe,
selbst
eine SIM-Karte drin hat.
Aber es ist, glaube ich,
doch in manchen Fällen ganz praktisch,
wenn man ordentliches WLAN im Auto hat.
Für Geräte
ohne SIM-Karte.
Ich habe mir nämlich zum Beispiel schon überlegt,
ob ich nicht einen Raspberry Pi fest installieren soll
in meinem Auto.
Und der muss ja irgendwie ins Internet, wenn ich darauf zugreifen will.
Ein Router.
Korrekt.
Das ist die Cisco-Aussprache.
Dein Auto
hat kein E-SIM mit WLAN-Hotspot.
Doch. Aber nur
über den offiziellen Tarif,
den man bei Fiat buchen kann. Das sehe ich nicht ein.
Also eine SIM-Karte hat
das Auto auf jeden Fall, weil du kannst
ja auf Online-Services damit zugreifen und von außen
aufs Auto zugreifen. Das geht nur über eine SIM-Karte.
Und man kann auch einen Hotspot-Service
buchen, aber das kostet extra. Und warum soll ich das machen,
wenn ich irgendwie 40G Volumen
habe, wo ich kaum was von brauche.
Wo Gruppe die Mods starten?
Dann schicken die das.
Nach dem Prime-Sub.
Und
es passen nur noch 5 Leute
rein in die Gruppe. Dann mache ich wirklich
dicht. Es reicht jetzt langsam.
Man muss auch mal
gönnen, aber irgendwann ist auch Schluss.
Meinst du, das muss ich wirklich in die Gruppe machen?
Nee, ich mache das wie die ganzen
Gruppenscammer. Wenn im Zweifelsfall
wirklich jemand was haben will, sage ich
sorry, warst dann leider zu spät. Ich habe gerade
geclosed. Gerade die Gruppe geclosed.
Aber du bist der erste, der
wieder rein darf, sobald ich sie öffne.
Ich kann auch nichts machen.
Die Gruppe ist halt voll jetzt.
Live-Coaching. Habe ich doch schon öfters
gemacht im Stream. Das ist tatsächlich eine Sache.
Wenn man das
Live-Coaching nennen kann.
Ich habe doch schon öfters mal meinen Senf zu
Sachen, die ich noch vor 10 Jahren anders gesehen habe
oder vor 20 Jahren anders gesehen habe, gegeben.
Zum Beispiel hätte ich vor 20 Jahren
Da war ich
20, by the way. So ungefähr.
Nie gedacht,
dass ich mich mal freiwillig
bewegen würde täglich und
dann auch noch
nicht nur täglich über 1,5 Stunden
laufen, sondern dann alle 2
Tage auch richtig rennen.
6 plus Kilometer.
Hätte ich nie gedacht.
Mit 20 hätte ich gesagt, ey was
glaube ich nicht, dass du das machst.
Ich meine, mir war mit 20 auch schon klar,
dass es gesundheitlich besser wäre
es zu machen, aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass ich
ne?
dass ich es gemacht hätte.
Wie sowas habe ich gesagt?
Du hast richtig, du hast recht.
Winzig war ich.
Ich bin doof.
Das ist so cringe, wenn ich das schon ausspreche.
Krafttraining auch, ne.
Ich will es ja mal nicht übertreiben.
Jetzt stellt euch mal vor,
ich hätte jetzt auch richtig krasse Muggis
und ich würde mir meinen Opel Agila wiederholen.
Da könnte ich mich ja
vor lauter Grills nicht mehr retten.
Ne, also Krafttraining nicht.
Vielleicht
überkommt es mich irgendwann mal auch ein paar
Gewichte zu heben.
Aber aktuell habe ich echt, macht mir das
wirklich Spaß, jeden zweiten Tag
hier meine Runde zu
rennen und jeden Tag halt
meine 1,5 Stunden zu laufen.
Das ist wirklich nice.
Ich muss sagen, also
eine Sache ist wirklich top.
Seitdem ich das mache,
also jetzt nicht seitdem ich
zusätzlich rennen gehe, sondern nachdem ich wirklich täglich
außer Sonntag vielleicht mal mit Ausnahme
über eine Stunde,
eineinhalb Stunden plus bewege,
ich habe fast
nichts mehr von den Problemen, die ich
noch vor
paar Jahren hatte.
Ich habe keine Kopfschmerzen mehr,
gar nichts, null.
Nichts mehr.
Mein Blutdruck ist so niedrig, dass ich
fast das Gefühl habe, da stimmt irgendwas
mit dem Gerät nicht.
Keine Rückenprobleme,
irgendwelche Verspannungen,
sowas.
Keine Schmerzen irgendwie hinten im
Bein oder so von zu viel gehockt.
Und
eine Sache muss ich sagen, wobei
da bin ich mir nicht sicher, woran das liegt,
ob das nicht vielleicht auch an den Prime-Subs
liegt.
Wir wissen ja alle, Prime-Sub gleich
High-IQ.
Es könnte aber auch sein,
ich weiß nicht, was ihr für realistisch erhaltet,
aber
es könnte auch sein, dass
seit ich angefangen habe, jetzt wirklich
alle zwei Tage auch nochmal ordentlich zu rennen,
dass ich mich irgendwie auch
mental wieder etwas fitter
fühle. Ist nicht so, dass ich
je gesagt hätte, Alter, mein
Hirn funktioniert nicht oder so, aber
mir kommt, mir kommt mein
Hirn
expandeter vor.
Seit ich,
seit ich angefangen habe zu rennen.
Es könnte auch an den Prime-Subs liegen, wie gesagt.
Ich finde, das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob das OpenWrt kann.
Aber OpenWrt kann eine Sache,
die UniFi nicht kann und
UniFi irgendwie auch keinen Bock hat zu unterstützen,
die ich aber für sehr wichtig halte,
was auch der Grund war, warum ich die rausgeschmissen habe.
Top Bit Donator.
Das weiß ich nicht. Sobald,
sobald Modgis, Modgis-Status
käuflich wird,
wenn man das einmal macht,
es läuft aus Bruder.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Ne, hast du einen Link?
Was ist der beste OpenWrt-Router?
Ich habe
keine Ahnung. Ich habe
OpenWrt sehr lange nicht mal selbst benutzt.
Stimmt, der Kollege hat da auch
mal so einen Gruppenscam, ne?
Ach, ich weiß nicht, was mit den Leuten los ist.
Irgendwann kann von der Musik
halten, was man will. Ihr wisst, dass deutscher Rap nicht unbedingt
meins ist, aber dass man dann auch irgendwie
versuchen muss, seinen Fans so krasses Geld
aus der Tasche zu ziehen mit irgendwelchen komischen
ähm
life-changing
Chat-Gruppen, wo man
lernt vom Boss, wie man das richtig krasse
Business macht. Ich weiß
nicht. Ja, und der hat da
auch mal irgendwie so ein Fitnessprogramm,
ja, das gab's auch.
Wobei ich mich lieber von Haftbefehl coachen
lassen würde, wie man, wie man sich im
Frankfurter Ghetto richtig bewegt.
Dass man nicht auf einmal sich auch wieder...
Ne, hat er sich ins Bein... Was, wie
war das? Hat er sich ins Bein gestochen
selbst oder aus Versehen selbst den Fuß geschossen?
Eins von beiden, war da doch.
Er hat's abgesagt, weil er das
Gescamme nicht leiden konnte. Ja, klar.
Ne, nachdem der Aufschrei zu groß war, vielleicht.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob er... Ich glaube, hat's... Ich glaube, Haftbefehl
hat er sich aus Versehen in den Fuß geschossen.
Boah, vor 1, 2 Jahren.
In die Wade hat er sich geschossen,
okay.
Hast du was mitbekommen von der Triathlon-WM?
Ja, ganz am Rande, dass
irgendeiner der richtig krassen
Triathlon-Leute irgendwie seinen letzten
Triathlon-Lauf gelaufen ist.
Aber sonst hab ich auch nicht viel davon mitbekommen.
Und das hab ich auch nur mitbekommen,
weil ich in letzter Zeit ein bisschen nach
Jogging-Rennen-Videos
gesucht hab auf YouTube.
Und jetzt YouTube meint, ja, Max,
dich interessieren bestimmt auch die aktuellen
Ironman-Ergebnisse oder sowas.
Für's Alter ist eine ausreichende Menge an
Muskelmasse wichtig.
Das klingt plausibel, ja.
Ja.
Ja, hast du sicherlich recht.
Da...
Okay, das ist, glaube ich, eines der Probleme,
die mein Vater nicht hat. Der hat jede Menge andere Probleme.
Aber ich glaube, Muskelprobleme
hat er nicht.
Der war früher so
wettkampfmäßiger
Gewichtsheber und dann Ringer.
Also, wenn er eins hat, sind's Muskeln.
Aber ansonsten hat er ganz andere Probleme.
Wann sollte man
circa anfangen, für die Abschlussprüfung
zum Physi zu lernen?
Hier haben bestimmt schon welche Empfang...
Ja, paar Wochen vorher.
Also, ich mein, du musst jetzt nicht zwei Jahre
vorher anfangen. Es reicht, es reicht,
wenn du weißt, wann deine Abschlussprüfung ist.
Wenn du da irgendwie so
mal anfängst, so, sagen wir mal,
zwei Monate
bevor die Prüfung ist, fängst
dir schon mal an, Gedanken zuzumachen
und suchst dir schon mal ein paar Prüfungen
im Internet raus. Und so richtig
interessant wird's eigentlich nur
ein paar Wochen, bevor die Prüfung ist.
Weil du vergisst es ja auch wieder. Es hat keinen Sinn,
wenn du jetzt einfach zwei Monate
vorher schon alle Prüfungen durchmachst und dann nix mehr
und hast wieder vergessen. Du kannst, du kannst
zwei Monate vorher schon mal reingucken,
fang an dir Gedanken zu machen, zwei Monate
vor der Prüfung. So, und so richtig
Prüfungen machen würde ich natürlich so die
zwei, drei Wochen vorher
richtig anfangen und alle Prüfungen durchmachen.
Jeden Tag, dass du jeden Tag mal
so eine Abschlussprüfung dir anguckst und jeden zweiten Tag
eine Abschlussprüfung anguckst, dass du einfach
in dieser Denkweise drin bist von der IHK,
das ist das Schwierigste.
Die Prüfungen an sich sind gar nicht schwer.
Zu verstehen, was die IHK wissen will, ist
eigentlich die, die Herausforderung.
Mikrotikgeräte haben meistens eine gute
Preisleistung, ja. Ja, genau
den meine ich. Man gibt zwar, dazu
muss es erstmal schneien, da sieht's ja aktuell nicht aus.
Ich könnte alternativ
anbieten, Leute, was haltet ihr davon?
Nachdem das nächste Schneestellsvideo,
ja, übrigens wer, wer,
ich weiß, dass immer noch Leute hier, also
was ist immer noch, das ist jetzt ein bisschen
falsch ausgedrückt, so meine ich's nicht.
Ich weiß, dass es immer mehr Leute hier gibt,
die Twitch tatsächlich, den Channel über Twitch
gefunden haben und nicht über YouTube.
Es gibt so ein, ein ungewolltes
Meme-Video von mir
auf YouTube, und zwar
ich weiß nicht, was
mit dem Video passiert ist auf YouTube, aber
eigentlich ist das Video mega langweilig,
aber es hat zwei Millionen Aufrufe.
Samus? Ups.
Falsch.
Das Video hat zwei Millionen
Aufrufe, Leute, ich habe bis heute
nicht die leiseste Ahnung, warum
dieses Video zwei Millionen Aufrufe hat.
Zumindest, es passiert in diesem Video nichts,
außer,
dass ich durch meinen, so ein bisschen
schneebedeckten
Garten laufe,
der noch nicht mal großartig
schneebedeckt ist. Der Teich ist
zugefroren.
Es gab schon so ein paar
kleine zweite Teile, ab und zu mal,
wo Schnee gelegen hat.
Hat nur keiner mitbekommen, weil die Videos
zu Recht eigentlich keine Sau interessieren.
Du weißt, wie mein Garten aussieht,
Pog.
Aber, also nachdem es nicht schneit,
kann ich ein Schneestells-Video
nicht bieten. Ich könnte
aber,
ja, ich weiß, es sind einige,
aber ich verstehe immer noch nicht,
warum YouTube das promoten wollte.
Aber ich könnte aber, müsst ihr mal
schreiben, was ihr davon haltet, ich könnte
mal ein Video machen,
wie nimmt man sowas auf?
Wir könnten mal sechs Kilometer
durch den Wald rennen zusammen.
Und, und,
könnt ihr, könnt ihr hören, wie ich am
halb am verrecken bin, je nachdem
wie schnell ich renne.
Wie nimmt man, wie nimmt
man sowas mit einer GoPro? Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Nee,
Twitch-Livestream mache ich nicht. Da werde ich noch
geleakt. Einmal Handy
runtergefallen oder Kamera falsch. Nee, nee,
nee, nee. Wie viel wiegst du
mittlerweile? Ja, zwischen
91 und 93.
Es schwankt, je nachdem wann und wie viel
ich anhab beim wiegen.
Ja, wenn ich, wenn ich nach dem Rennen
Gachi Roll
auf die Waage,
dann ist es eher 91, irgendwas.
Und wenn ich in
in Jeans und nach dem Essen, dann
ist es 93,8 oder so.
Also ich habe, ich
bin guter Dinge, dass ich es
schaffe, bis Ende des Jahres, wenn ich
weitermache mit meinem alle zwei Tage
Rennen auf
unter 90.
Und hat letztens im Chat einer geschrieben,
dass ich mir gar nicht
so viel Gedanken mache. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt.
Ich habe mich mit so Theorie beschäftige ich mich ja immer relativ
wenig.
Letztens hat einer im Chat geschrieben, Max,
mach dir nicht so viele Gedanken, wenn du am Anfang nicht so viel
abnimmst. Dadurch, dass du, also
dadurch, dass man, dadurch, dass
du jetzt erst das quasi seit einem Monat machst,
habe ich jetzt auch erstmal viele Muskeln
dabei gekriegt, so in Beinen
und Wade und alles, so dass ich
quasi weniger Fett habe und mehr Muskeln und deswegen
sieht man es nicht so sehr auf der Waage.
Wie groß bist du?
Ich bin 1,74.
Echt, sie rennt da auch durch den
Wald, ja?
Und hast
deinen Rauchmelder gekauft.
Du wunderst dich jetzt vielleicht, woher
weiß er das noch? Tja,
manche Sachen merke ich mir.
Ihr könnt aber nicht erwarten, dass ich das in zwei Tagen noch weiß.
Manche Sachen habe ich so
im Hinterkopf, die sind aber
eine Woche später wieder weg, aber irgendwie
manchmal ploppt sowas auf, ja.
Ja.
Lass mal gucken, können wir uns noch ein paar Videos angucken?
Was haben wir denn hier noch Schönes?
Sunshine,
ah ja, nee, nee, das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Ah, Maurice hat ein Video gemacht über Diablo 4,
das wollte ich mir angucken.
Chatge, spielt noch jemand von euch Diablo 4?
Ich habe es ja zu Release komplett verdrängt
und habe nie damit angefangen,
habe es mir nie gekauft, obwohl das immer hieß,
eigentlich ein richtig gutes Game wieder geworden.
Aber in den letzten
paar Wochen,
gerade auch mit der neuen Season,
ist es enorm still um
Diablo 4 geworden.
Wie sieht es bei euch aus? Spielt noch
irgendjemand von euch?
Also, ich habe nicht
vor, es mir noch zu kaufen.
Wo ich viel mehr Bock drauf habe, ist,
wenn irgendwann mal Path of Exile 2 rauskommt.
Diablo 4 ist dead, gell? Gucken wir uns vielleicht
doch mal das Video von
Maurice an.
Was er so zum Besten zu geben hat.
Ich spiele im Durchschnitt zwei Stunden
pro Woche. Okay, so ganz ehrlich,
das könnte ich nicht. Wenn ich so ein Game spiele
wie Diablo oder generell so ein
grind heavy Game, dann muss
ich entweder krassen Kreisel-Grind machen
für ein paar Wochen und dann wieder warten
bis die nächste Season kommt oder
ich spiele es erst gar nicht.
Titan Quest 2?
Wirklich?
Wurde das angekündigt?
Das habe ich überhaupt nicht mitbekommen.
Ja, Titan Quest
war mega nice.
Das würde ich tatsächlich, das würde ich tatsächlich
feiern, wenn es Titan Quest 2
gäbe. Das Original ist
so alt, das kennt wahrscheinlich kaum noch einer.
Super Nintendo-Spiele?
Da gibt es ja auch glücklicherweise
sehr viele.
Was ist ein gutes Startgehalt für ein Fahrradformat
der Iron Man's Entwicklung?
Es kommt immer ganz drauf an.
Region? Branche?
Was sind deine Spezialitäten?
Kann man immer schlecht
sagen. Ich sage
immer, dass
also auf die Frage, auf die Frage hin,
ja, sage ich immer das, was ich verdient habe
und was es jetzt hochgerechnet wäre.
Also, mein Einstiegsgehalt, ich bin
zwar nicht Anwendungsentwickler, aber
das Einzige, was ich euch sagen kann. Mein
Einstiegsgehalt damals waren 33.600.
Das sind glaube ich
hochgerechnet heute
irgendwie 45k so
in dem Dreh.
Aber hier haben wir noch ein paar Spiegel, haben wir noch so einen komischen
Rechner, Inflationsrechner.
Ja.
33.500,
genau, das waren mal
45k. Also würde ich
sagen, ist ein ganz gutes Einstiegsgehalt
45k.
Ich kann es dir aber nicht wirklich sagen, weil
mir da die
aktuellen Vergleichswerte fehlen.
Sagt mir nix.
Lasst uns doch mal gucken. Komm, wir gucken uns
ein bisschen was noch an. So, entweder
wir gucken uns, wir können uns ein Video von Maurice angucken,
so Diablo 4. Oh, was ist das?
Putting together
my own retro gaming. Oh, da habe ich
Bock drauf, Leute. Boomer!
Boomer guckt Boomer-Technik.
Ich stehe ja auf solche Videos.
Es ist unglaublich unsinnig,
niemand, jetzt mal
Hand aufs Herz, wie
der Kaboom gesagt hätte,
aber es ist
eigentlich total unsinnig,
sowas zu bauen.
Weil du kannst
quasi alles Interessante
in irgendeiner Art und Weise heute immer noch
auf Rechnern spielen. Okay,
vielleicht war das ein bisschen zu
viel des Guten. Es gibt jetzt Leute, die sagen, nein,
Max, aber mein Lieblingsspiel
von 1997,
das ist komplett
unplayable. Also, du kannst
prinzipiell alle ganz alten Spiele spielen
mit sowas wie Dosbox zum Beispiel.
Die richtig
großen Games von damals, die funktionieren
heute. Ich meine, sogar Siedler 2
läuft mit einem
Mod,
ich glaube sogar ohne Mod,
heute noch auf dem aktuellen
PC.
Also, ich sehe das
sehr nischenmäßig.
Das einzige, wofür ich es wirklich sinnvoll
halte, wenn man wirklich die komplette
Retro-Experience
haben will, und dazu zählt für
mich auch sowas wie
EAX-Sound und
Voodoo-Graphics, wenn man
mit, wie hieß das Ding, wie hieß das?
DirectX von Voodoo
Glide 3D oder sowas
spielen will. Okay,
das lass ich mir gefallen. Also, wenn man
wirklich so eins
hundertprozentig haben wollte,
wie man das, keine Ahnung, 1998
gespielt hat, okay.
Okay, dann, dann
lass ich mir das gefallen. Aber,
ich guck mir trotzdem unglaublich gerne solche Videos
an, weil mich das immer
an so die beste PC-Zeit
erinnert. Für mich.
Deswegen gucken wir das jetzt
auch einfach. Ich hoffe, das
taugt. Ich kenn den Channel nicht.
Oh, nice Porn-Musik
im Hintergrund.
Ist das etwa
Windows ME im Hintergrund?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Das ist, das ist
mit diesem, das ist Windows ME, oder?
Mit diesen Icons.
Und das war damals
der letzte Schrei, diese ergonomischen
Tastaturen, die fanden damals alle geil.
Mittlerweile ist das nicht mehr so
angesagt, aber das ist
das, was ich meine. Du kannst alle diese
Spiele heute auch auf modernen Rechner
spielen. Wobei ich mir beim ersten
Stronghold nicht so sicher
bin, ob das, zumindest die
Version, die es damals noch auf
CDs gab, läuft.
Aber Baldur's Gate
1 und 2 kannst du definitiv
spielen. Auch die Originalfassung
auf neuen PCs.
Sei es mit irgendeinem
Fan-Patch oder so.
Und die Enhanced Editions auf jeden
Fall eh. Da kenn ich auch
einen, der so eine Maus hat.
Das ist so eine
Hochkant-Maus, ja.
Warcraft 2 war mega.
Also ich muss sagen, Warcraft
ist für mich eindeutig das Dreier.
Also ich habe Warcraft
nie großartig Competitive Multiplayer
gespielt. Aber die Warcraft 3
Kampagne ist, finde ich,
bis heute
eigentlich immer noch
eines
der Besten, die je
gemacht wurden.
Gibt so ein paar Sachen, das fällt
einem immer so aus dem Stehgreif nicht
direkt ein, ja.
Aber wenn man dann weit drüber nachdenkt,
sei es jetzt Filme,
Spiele,
meinetwegen auch Bücher, falls
jemand Bücher liest.
Ich habe in meinem Leben nicht
viele Bücher gelesen.
Also so
Fiction-Bücher, also jetzt
Sachbücher und so
habe ich jede Menge gelesen, aber
wirklich Storybücher
und so habe ich nicht.
Ich habe niemals Harry Potter
gelesen und so, hat mich nie interessiert,
interessiert mich heute auch nicht.
Ich habe noch nicht mal Herr der Ringe gelesen,
weil ich es übelst langatmig fand.
Also es gibt verdammt wenig Bücher,
die ich wirklich gelesen habe.
Ich zähle da mal
hörbuchmäßig dabei.
Nicht viel, nicht viel.
Also ich habe mir früher
jede Gamestar gekauft.
Generals war auch mega.
Also eines der besten Stories, die ich je
gelesen, ist das falsche Wort,
konsumiert habe.
Max, ich habe wirklich Angst
darauf zu gehen, bevor die Technik so weit ist.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, die werden wir alle nicht erleben.
Nicht in der Form, wie man sich das jetzt
Science-Fiction-mäßig vielleicht vorstellt.
Also die beste, eine der besten
und lustigsten und
wie soll man sagen,
ähm
herausstechendsten so Buchstorys,
die ich kenne,
die ich je mir zu Gemüte
geführt habe, ist
wie hieß das?
Das ist uralt, vielleicht weiß gar nicht,
ob das noch jemand kennt von euch.
Die Farben der Magie,
genau.
Das da, das ist der erste
Scheibenwelt-Roman.
Kennt das jemand von euch?
Ich habe, ich, das ist,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ich glaube, das ist das einzige,
was ich kenne aus der ganzen Serie.
Und das ist glaube ich
auch das erste
aus der Serie.
Das ist wirklich sehr unique.
Es ist teilweise schon echt bescheuert,
wo ich so denke, okay.
Aber ich glaube, das ist,
was Buchstorys angeht,
eines der einprägsamsten gewesen.
Und ich habe nicht viel, also Bücher
und Buchstorys gibt es echt nicht viel,
was ich gelesen habe. Habe ich geguckt, ja.
Ich habe Season 1
geguckt, fand Season 1 relativ gut.
Ich habe Season 2 angefangen und dachte mir,
übelst lahmarschig. Aber
dann ist mir es gedämmert, woran das liegt.
Die waren ja schon durch mit der Buchvorlage
von Season 1.
Die mussten sich irgendwas aus den Fingern saugen
für Season 2. Und das ist halt
aufgefallen.
Ich habe dann gar nicht weiter geguckt.
Ich habe nur die ersten, keine Ahnung, 2, 3 Folgen
geguckt von Season 2. Hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
Aber Season 1 war echt gut.
GameStar habe ich mir damals jede gekauft.
So, lass mal gucken. Also,
wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ich wollte mir das Retro-PC-Video anschauen.
Ansonsten überlege ich gerade,
was gibt es, fällt mir gar nicht so viel ein.
So, Stories gelesen. Ja,
ich habe mir Herr der Ringe
als Hörvariante gegeben.
Die Zwerge habe ich
gelesen, tatsächlich, als Buch.
Kennt das jemand?
Das ist auch so, auch Fantasy-Kram.
Ansonsten, was habe ich?
Ich habe echt keine Ahnung.
Es ist wenig, es ist wirklich wenig,
was ich gelesen habe an Büchern.
Ich habe das Witcher.
Die Witcher Short Stories
habe ich, habe ich,
mir vorlesen lassen.
Also, das allererste Witcher-Buch,
was nur Kurzgeschichten waren,
das habe ich mir gekauft
bei Audible vor einer Weile.
Aber ansonsten,
ich bin kein großer Bücherleser.
So, aber jetzt gucken wir echt mal in das Video,
sonst wird da nie was.
Oh, guck dir mal da, sehe ich da unten richtig
ein Zip-Drive!
Iomega!
100 MB!
Chat, erinnert sich da noch jemand dran?
Waren das 100 MB
oder bringe ich es jetzt durcheinander?
Nee, es waren 100 MB, gell?
So was wollte ich immer haben, hatte ich nie.
Ich glaube, die konnten so viel
speichern. Was war denn da innen drinne?
War da in so einem Zip,
waren da Bänder, waren da Bänder drin in so einem
Zip-Drive?
Zip-Drive? Äh, ja.
Teardown.
Waren da Bänder drin oder wie hat das funktioniert?
Nee, da waren
irgendwelche Magnetplatten
oder so drinne.
Keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert hat.
Ey, das ist was anderes.
Nun gut. Aber Zip-Drive
wollte ich immer haben, hatte ich nie.
Es gab da noch so eine andere Technik, die nannte
sich
O-Drive oder sowas.
O-Drive?
Das hatte 120 MB. Irgendwie sowas.
Aber 120 MB,
hieß das O-Drive?
Hm.
Nee.
Ey, das ist irgendwas anderes gewesen.
Egal, schaut mal her.
Oh, guck mal da, eine...
Ist das...
Nee, ist nicht...
Okay, lasst mal gucken, was baut er sich denn
zusammen.
Erstmal auf dem Mainboard rumfräsen.
Wunderbar.
Zip-Drives waren doch wie Floppys.
Nee, die waren nicht kompatibel.
Die waren ein bisschen dicker, ja.
Nicht richtig.
Aber, ey,
gar nicht genau.
Wie im Flick.
Nices Case?
Nices Case.
Richtig schönes
Old-School-Case.
Das hatte damals übrigens jeder
Überall war so ein Energy Star draufgeklebt.
Bei vielen Rechnern, wenn der Rechner gebootet ist, dann stand auch irgendwas von Energy Star.
Das war so ein Ding, das haben damals die Hersteller gedacht, die Leute geben da was drauf, wenn da der Energy Star ist.
Hat ja für den Klimawandel nicht so viel gebracht, der Energy Star.
Man muss aber auch sagen, dass zur damaligen Zeit war es bei Gehäusen echt schon so,
dass eigentlich je größer, je cooler war man.
Das war die Zeit, wo man Big Tower hatte, ohne dass es wirklich Sinn gemacht hat, einen Big Tower zu haben.
Man hat da natürlich damals noch ein bisschen mehr eingebaut im Rechner, weil es noch viel weniger Onboard gab.
Also ihr müsst euch vorstellen,
damals hatte kein Mainboard eine Netzwerkkarte Onboard.
Die hatten auch...
Du hast damals eh mehr eingebaut.
Du hast eine Netzwerkkarte eingebaut, du hast noch ein Modem eingebaut, du hast eine Soundkarte eingebaut.
Viele Mainboards hatten dann nicht mal Onboard-Sound.
Zusätzliche Extensions, alles mögliche.
Eine Fritz-Karte zum Beispiel wurde damals oft noch eingebaut.
Und du hattest...
Durchaus damals im Rechner vier, fünf Add-on-Karten stecken, plus eine Grafikkarte,
wo hingegen heute eigentlich außer einer Grafikkarte und vielleicht noch einer Capture-Karte,
vielleicht einer Capture-Karte, eigentlich nichts mehr drin steckt.
Was habt ihr sonst großartig im Rechner noch stecken?
Manch einer eine 10G-Netzwerkkarte vielleicht noch, wenn ihm das 2,5 von Mainboard nicht reicht.
2D-Grafikkarte, 3D-Karte.
In Zeiten von Voodoo-Grafikkarten hattest du...
Natürlich auch noch eins oder zwei Voodoo-2-Karten drinne, plus noch eine normale Grafikkarte,
dass du dein Windows-Desktop sehen konntest.
Natürlich, ja klar.
Das musste dann mit so einem Pass-Through-Kabel durchgeschliffen werden,
was die Bildqualität auch nicht gerade besser gemacht hat.
Alles VGA.
So.
So as you can imagine, I was pretty jazzed to find one that was still brand new.
There's four 5.25 and two 3.5-inch bays on the front, but what makes this case distinctive,
is this translucent teal swoosh shape.
I always thought this design aesthetic was lots of fun,
as it signified a much more interesting time in computing and consumer electronics.
It came with a standard ATX-IO-Shield already installed, along with...
Übrigens, PC-Gehäuse, zur damaligen Zeit haben ja noch total viele Leute geraucht.
Damals waren halt PC-Gehäuse richtig schnell gelb, also in vielen Wohnungen.
...the power supply that I wanted to take a closer look at.
The case sides are held on with screws, so I made a mental note to track down some thumb screws later on.
Zwar übrigens vollkommen normal, dass Gehäuse damals schwer zu öffnen waren und teilweise gar nicht richtig entgradet,
wenn ihr nicht aufgepasst habt, und diese ganzen Komfort-Sachen von Verschlüsse zum Auf- und Zumachen,
zum Klipsen anstatt zum Schrauben und so, ordentliche Schrauben, die man nur mit der Hand... gab's alles nicht.
...
Also, ich hab mich nie so sehr geschnitten an einem Gehäuse, dass ich jetzt irgendwelche Narben hätte.
Also, eine Sache, die ich mal geschafft hab, die ist aber noch gar nicht so lange her, und die hat auch mit dem Gehäuse nichts zu tun,
Ich habe es mal geschafft, mir einen Pinheader in die Ferse zu stecken, aus Versehen.
Das tut weh.
Also nicht den kompletten Header, nur so ein Ding.
Aber da hat man wieder gemerkt, dass Schmerzempfinden und Berührungsempfinden entkoppelt sind.
Zumindest im Fuß so ein bisschen.
Denn ich habe es gespürt, dass ich mir das gerade in die Ferse gestochen habe.
Aber es hat erst eine Sekunde später wehgetan.
Ich habe das noch gemerkt.
Das lag irgendwo hier unter dem Schreibtisch.
Irgendwo hier unter dem Schreibtisch.
Irgendwie runtergefallen bei irgendwas Gebasteltes, ausgepackt, keine Ahnung, runtergefallen.
Und ich weiß es noch, ich hatte keine Socken an.
Und ich wollte mich am Boden mit meinem Stuhl ein bisschen nach vorne ziehen.
Der Stuhl war ein bisschen weit hinten.
Ich wollte mich nach vorne ziehen.
Mit dem Fuß über.
Und da bin ich halt mit der Ferse über den Teppich und habe gemacht so, zack, nach vorne mit der Ferse, also nach vorne gezogen, dass der Stuhl nach vorne geht.
Und auf einmal spüre ich und höre ich es bei mir an der Ferse.
Also ich habe es gehört, meine Ferse hat mir ein bisschen dickere Haut.
An der Ferse habe ich es auf einmal gehört, hat es so richtig gerade so, so als würde gerade, wie wenn ihr irgendwie ein bisschen was dickeres so durch Papier durchstecht.
Es hat so einen richtigen Durchstech-Sound.
Und ich habe es auch gespürt, aber es hat nicht wehgetan.
Aber nach 1-2 Sekunden habe ich dann gemerkt, au, mein Bein, mein Fuß.
Man hat es ein bisschen spiket, meine Ferse, man hat es ein bisschen spiket, au.
Ja gut, ich meine, ich habe es dann rausgezogen und so, alles gut.
Es ist jetzt keine wahnsinnig schlimme Verletzung daraus entstanden.
Ich hatte bloß ein paar Tage wirklich Probleme beim Auftreten danach.
Ah, so ein Ding, so ein Ding geht schon.
Ich meine, wie lange wird denn das sein?
1 Zentimeter oder so?
34 Jahre her.
Also was ich da habe ist, ich habe, also da habe ich nichts, ich habe am, lass mal gucken, welche Seite ist es das?
Rechtes Knie ist es hier, rechtes, rechtes, rechtes Knie und ich glaube außen hier am linken, zumindest am rechten Knie sieht man das heute noch.
Da bin ich mal übelst mit dem Fahrrad, als ich klein war, da war ich keine Ahnung, 8 oder so, richtig lang her.
Da bin ich übelst.
Und dann bin ich mit dem Fahrrad aufs Maul gefallen, auf nem, auf nem, auf nem Steinweg, der auch noch so richtig raues Pflaster hatte.
Da bin ich übelst aufs Maul gefallen, aufs Knie und das hat auch geblutet als fuck und ich kann mich da heute noch dran erinnern.
Ich hatte da gefühlt wochenlang irgendwie so, so, so, so, so, ja wie das halt aussieht, wenn das halt wieder zuwächst, ja und so, so, so, so.
Wie heißt denn das so?
so braun halt ist, wenn das so
zuwächst. Und das sieht man
heute noch. Also, man sieht, dass an der Stelle
mal ziemlich, ziemlich große
Verletzung war.
So, aber lang genug erzählt. Schorf
heißt das, genau. Aber lang genug über
irgendwelche Verletzungen. Ich wollte mir eigentlich das Video angucken.
Oh ja. Oh, nice.
Nice.
Blub.
Kaltgeräte-Kabel. Übrigens, so auch so ein Ding,
was sich ja 20 Jahre nicht geändert hat, ne?
Diese 0815-Kaltgeräte-Stecker.
Oh, guck mal hier. Das ist der dicke,
der dicke
PS2-Vorgänger.
Ne, PS2?
Ist das PS... Ja, es hieß PS2, oder?
Das war diese DIN-Stecker
für Tastaturen damals noch.
Deer? Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Kennt jemand Deer als Hersteller?
Erstmal, erst mal das richtig
gute, 15 Jahre alte
LC Power rein.
Okay. Ja, die sind ganz brauchbar,
denke ich.
Warum nicht das gute
China-Chinesen-LC-Power-Netzteil?
OMG!
Guck dir mal,
wie klein der hat, der X-Stecker.
Wie klein der damals noch gewesen ist.
Heute ist der ATX-Stecker, gefühlt, doppelt so lang.
Ne, ist er nicht. Ich glaube, der ATX-Stecker
heute hat auch nur noch einen Vierer mehr.
Aber damals war der richtig
mini.
Which hints at the next component
we'll be looking at.
While this case dates back to the late
90s, I wanted to target the early
2000s with this build.
Specifically something to run
Windows XP.
Windows XP? Okay, da, also,
da fällt mir jetzt wirklich nicht viel ein,
was exklusiv auf Windows XP läuft
und später nicht mehr.
Windows 98 und ME und sowas
hätte ich ja verstanden, aber okay.
Übrigens, wir wissen gleich, wir sind im
Kokona Land. 115.
Some people are confused
by the concept of retro gaming
on XP, since a decent
selection of titles still run
on modern versions of Windows.
But not all of them
will, and of course, tinkering
with period-correct hardware
is part of the retro charm.
And here's what we'll be
powering this system. A motherboard
from Intel, Model D845.
Guter...
Das ist doch AGP, oder?
Ja, das ist doch AGP,
das ist doch kein PC-Express.
GEBV2.
That's a bit of alphabet soup, but it's a
solid ATX board that was introduced
in late 2002.
6 PCI slots plus...
Ein PC von 2002? Das geht
für mich schon fast nicht mehr als retro
durch.
...durch...
Ja, bester, bester AGP-Stecker.
Er hatte damals, er hatten damals
schon dieses komische zum Einhaken.
Kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Ich hätte, ich, ich habe gedacht,
das haben sie erst mit PCI-Express erfunden,
dieses zum Einhaken.
IDE-Anschlüsse?
Das ist ein 4-Gigahertz-Prozessor und ein 1-Gigabyte-RAM.
Gar nichts übel.
Das wäre ein perfekter Fitt für Windows XP.
Also für die Zeit? Also ist es auf jeden Fall eines der deutlich schnelleren Windows-XP-Systeme.
...der deutlich schnelleren Windows-XP-Systeme war, bevor ich zu weit in die Assemblung gegangen bin.
Der Heatsink wurde einfach vom CPU-Socket ungeklebt und sicherlich sah es so aus, als wäre das
immer noch der original Pace.
Das Rauschen war das, was ich erwartet hatte.
Das ist ein Socket 478-Pennium-4.
Oh.
Das ist schon fast kein Retro mehr.
Da könnte man ja fast Windows 7 noch drauf installieren.
Oder was heißt fast?
Man könnte da sogar wahrscheinlich ohne Probleme Windows 7 drauf installieren.
Allerdings ist der Pentium 4 vermutlich kein Dual-Core, sondern ein Single-Core.
Also das wäre schon hardcore lahm.
Ich glaube, es gab Pentium 4s mit Dual-Core.
Das war das Allerartigste.
Das war das allererste Dual-Core, was die hatten.
Ich glaube, die sind Pentium 4D oder sowas.
Ja, sowas in der Richtung gab es, glaube ich.
Warum ist da ein Loch?
Wo?
Wo ist ein Loch?
Da!
Eine exzellente Frage.
Warum ist da ein Loch?
Kann das sein, dass das gar kein Loch ist, sondern einfach nur ein Tropfen vom Reinigungsmittel?
Nee, das hat ein Loch.
Warum hat die CPU ein Loch?
Hatten die damals alle ein Loch?
Weil da ist ja offensichtlich nichts drunter.
Das habe ich doch nicht gesehen.
Das waren solide Sachen.
Das ist das, was ich gesehen habe.
Das habe ich auf der Hand gehabt.
Das ist ein solides CPU-Kuhler, also gibt es keinen Grund, es nicht mehr zu verwenden.
Guckt mal, mit wie kleinen Furzlüftern man damals ausgekommen ist.
Ich habe die Möglichkeit genommen, ein bisschen Kabelmanagement zu machen.
Also beim Pentium 4 haben sie ja festgestellt, dass ihre Roadmap nicht mehr funktioniert.
Dass der Scheiß einfach zu heiß wird mit höheren Taktraten.
Pentium 4 war so das Ende der Fahnenstange für Single-Core CPUs.
Das war das Ende der Fahnenstange für Single-Core CPUs.
Klar, es hat sich auch vieles verbessert.
Die Single-Core-Performance ist heute trotzdem deutlich besser als bei einem Pentium 4.
Aber die Taktraten haben sich nicht so extrem mehr verbessert.
Vielleicht noch knapp verdoppelt, wenn die Boost anhaben.
4,8.
Aber ansonsten merkst du halt den CPUs heute an, dass da deutlich mehr drauf ist.
Mit so einem kleinen Popelüfter kannst du da heute nicht mal anstinken gegen die Abwärme.
Ich meine, das ist mein erster Rechner mit Wasserkühlung, den ich hier habe.
Weil das Ding eben richtig reinhaut.
Da, das ist viel besser.
Dieser Motherboard wurde während der sogenannten Kapazitätsverlust-Ära hergestellt, als
schlechte Kappen ihre Wege in eine Vielzahl von Elektroniken gemacht haben.
Glücklicherweise sieht dieser in guter Form aus.
Zumindest für jetzt.
Der Motherboard hat eine deutliche Verwendung von Porten.
Audio.
10100 Ethernet.
VGA.
Parallel.
Serial.
4 USB 2.0 und PS2 für Keyboard und Maus.
Oh.
Guck mal, da hat es schon Sound und Netzwerk onboard.
Ja klar, ich meine, Windows XP 2002, da war das auch schon so, aber davor war das nicht
so.
Ist auch gar nicht so lang gewesen, dass es dort, dass es Standard war.
Onboard Audio und Onboard Sound.
Also vier Jahre davor wäre das schon.
Wäre dann hätte das anders ausgesehen.
Weil vier Jahre davor haben die Leute auch teilweise noch BNC-Netzwerkkarten gehabt mit
einem Terminator und einem BNC-Kabel und einem T-Stück und sowas.
Auf jeden Fall hat sich der I.O.-Schild, der auf der Kiste gekommen ist, nicht gemessen.
Und der Board kam zu mir ohne den originalen.
Missing Shields sind eine kleine Leidenschaft von mir, also habe ich es geschafft, eine
Verwendung von Ebay zu bekommen, für nur 10 Franken mit Schiff.
Ich habe es auf der Kiste mitgebracht, aber es ist nicht so einfach.
Ich habe es auf der Kiste geliefert, aber es ist nicht so einfach.
Back of the case, but of course these things never go in all that easily, so I went with
the old school trick of tapping it into place with the handle of a screwdriver.
There, see?
No problem.
Erst mal das Ding reingeprügelt.
There were a couple of extra leads on the power supply that I bundled up to keep out
of the way.
Then it came time to get the motherboard standoff screwed in, so I emptied the bag of included
screws.
Das war aber damals schon eines der besseren Gehäuse, wenn das so umfangreich war, was
damit geliefert wurde.
Also ich hatte damals auch richtig billige Gehäuse, da musstest du Schrauben dir von
anderen Geräten raussuchen, um da ordentlich was einzubauen.
Und, und, diese Abstandshalter fürs Mainboard, ne?
Ich war damals viel zu blöd, ich wusste gar nicht, dass man die benutzen muss.
Glücklicherweise hatten die meisten Gehäuse schon welche drin.
Und wie, Abstandshalter?
Wer braucht denn sowas?
Einfach Mainboard ins Gehäuse reinklatschen und gut ist's.
A test fit with the board showed which ones I'd need to populate and I got them put in
with a socket bit.
This is way better than trying to tighten standoffs with a pair of pliers.
One place where this case went cheap was the use of breakaway blanks for the expansion
card slots.
So I picked which ones I figured I'd need and got them knocked out.
Ja, alte Gehäuse, ich vermisse sie in der Anwendung nicht.
Ich fand, okay, ich muss sagen, ich find die Optik heute von PCs deutlich, ähm, gefälliger
als damals.
Aber ich guck...
Ich guck mir alte Gehäuse und alte Rechner trotzdem gerne an, weil's mich eben an die
Zeit erinnert, wo das Zeug angesagt war.
Nicht, dass ich's heute noch haben möchte, ja, aber richtig, Boomer-Modus aktiviert,
ja klar.
Aber das ist ein ganz gutes Board, ich mein, das hat ein AGP, ein Onboard Sound, ein Onboard
Netzwerk und sechs PCI-Steckplätze.
Also das ist schon eines für die damaligen Zeiten.
Echt.
Das ist schon eines der besseren Boards gewesen.
...was a time of rapid growth, so little details like this tend to go a long way, even
if they're the norm now.
Next up was connecting the front panel LEDs and buttons, and the pinout was clearly labeled
on the board...
Oh!
...so I didn't have to break out the manual.
Da hat er aber Glück gehabt!
Ich mein, damit haben die Hersteller heute noch Probleme, dass du diesen Müll anschließen
kannst.
Das ist ja schon mal was.
Und ich mein, ich war damals schon froh, wenn die Markierung drauf war.
Wo der Anfang ist.
Ja.
A bummer is that it expected a two-pin header for the power LED, but the case used an older
three-pin style.
There's an old-school fix for this, too, and it's to simply snip the connector down
the middle with a pair of flush cutters.
Turn the two halves 90 degrees, and they'll nest side by side as if they were a two-pin
version.
I got the motherboard's power supply connections sorted next, trying to keep the cabling neat.
As I went.
Unfortunately while the case...
Wie klein!
Wie klein der ATX-Stecker damals einfach war.
...trying to keep the cabling neat.
Mini-ATX-Stecker.
...as I went.
Unfortunately while the case...
Oh, der gute PC-Speaker!
Ja, sowas haben die Gehäuse heute auch nicht mehr.
Ist auch ganz gut so.
Aber nen Onboard-Peeper haben die meisten Mainboards noch.
Das stimmt.
Und vom Preis her...
Vom Preis her auch.
Du konntest dir damals drei Richtlinien anbieten.
Das stimmt.
Und vom Preis her...
Vom Preis her auch.
Du konntest dir damals drei richtig gute PCs bauen.
Für den Preis von einem.
Oder von einer 4090 oder so.
Na, Preis von einem PC.
Also wenn du damals 2000...
Damals hast du für 1000 Mark schon ordentlich einen PC gekriegt.
Und 2000 war wirklich exzellenter PC.
Ich rede noch von vor 2000.
Damals haben High-End-Grafikkarten 250 Mark gekostet.
Zum Beispiel die TNT-1-Karten, die es damals gab und sowas.
Also...
Gut, Voodoo-SLI war natürlich damals auch schon teurer.
Aber bei weitem nicht so krass wie heute, eine 4090 oder sowas.
Das stimmt.
Damals brauchte man alle zwei Jahre eine neue CPU, GPU.
Die war nach eineinhalb Jahren eigentlich hoffnungslos veraltet.
Damals ging es aber auch rasend schnell, die Entwicklung.
Es gab einen ziemlich großen PC-Hörer.
Es gab keinen Header auf dem Board.
Nicht wirklich ein Problem am Ende, denn es hat einen Onboard-Buzzer.
Ich meine, da muss ich das mal überlegen.
Wir sind dort in ein paar Jahren von sowas wie Doom zu sowas wie Far Cry gegangen.
So, also guck mal.
Far Cry 1 Release Date.
War 2000...
2004.
Und Doom war glaube ich 1994.
Also in diesen zehn Jahren sind wir quasi von sowas hier...
Wir sind von Doom-Graphics...
Das ist nicht Doom 1 Graphics.
Wir sind von sowas hier...
Wir sind innerhalb von zehn Jahren von sowas hier zu sowas hier gegangen.
Und das ist noch nicht mal...
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das war mega für die damalige Zeit.
Far Cry 1.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Da sind Welten einfach dazwischen.
Far Cry 1 geht heute noch halbwegs durch, als man kann es sich durchaus angucken.
Und für viele Leute, die nicht so sehr auf Retro und Pixel stehen, die würden den Doom heute im Leben nicht anschauen.
Nochmal zehn Jahre und dann hast du BF3.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Aber ich finde der Sprung von Doom-Graphics zu Far Cry-Graphics war natürlich...
Und natürlich in der Zwischenzeit kamen ganz viele Zwischenstationen noch.
Aber in den zehn Jahren ist so extrem viel passiert.
Ich glaube 1993 bis 2003 oder sagen wir 1994 bis...
Ich weiß gar nicht genau, wann Doom 1 Release war.
1994, ich glaube 1993.
In diesen zehn Jahren von Doom bis Far Cry 1...
Es hat sich davor 3D-Graphics nicht so schnell entwickelt.
Davor gab es ja kaum wirklich 3D-Graphics.
Und Doom war ja auch noch nicht so richtig alles komplett 3D-Graphics.
Und das wird sich auch nie wieder so schnell in den Detailgrad ändern.
Ja, grafisch nicht so sehr.
Es war gut.
Cort 4 war grafisch durchaus nice.
Hat aber auch eher in anderen Bereichen Maßstab geändert.
Aber Far Cry 1 war für die damalige Zeit einfach das optisch beste Game, was man sich vorstellen konnte.
Also in den Jahren hat sich wirklich enorm viel getan.
Ich hab vergessen, warum wir stehen geblieben sind.
Das ist ja auch ein bisschen schwierig.
Genau.
Immer mehr Lüfter Luft reinziehen lassen ins Gehäuse, als rauspusten lassen.
...dass es ein Racket geben wird.
Es ist ein Noctua?
Es ist glücklicherweise kein hässlicher brauner Noctua.
...dass der Fan direkt reinpustet.
Es scheint auch nicht so weit auf die Luftflasche zu schlagen.
Aber das Inlet ist es im selben Fall.
Das ist eine andere Sache. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wer das gedacht hat.
Das war okay, aber ich musste etwas darüber machen.
Die Metro-Hackerei war in Ordnung. Ich habe den vorderen Bezel ungeklippt, dann einfach den Fan-Grill mit einem alten Paar Kuttern ausgeschnitten.
Es ist egal, ob die Ergebnisse schlecht sind, denn du wirst das niemals sehen, wenn du den Fan und den Bezel in Ordnung hättest.
Das sollte sehr viel mit dem Luftfluss helfen.
Der Fan schnappte in den Käse, dann der Käse schnappte in den Käse.
Der Lüfter war auf dem Motherboard in Ordnung.
Aber dann wollte ich einige grundlegende Tests machen, um sicherzustellen, dass alles funktioniert, bevor ich weitergekommen bin.
Die Maschine hat sich aufgeräumt, wie es sollte, aber es gab ein ziemlich ominöses...
Ja, Festplatten-Spin-Up war eh immer noch das Beste.
Festplatten-Spin-Up war eh immer noch das Beste.
Das lief an und dann hat es gemacht, klack, genau, klack, ja, klack hat es gemacht, weil der Lesekopf rausgeschwenkt ist und warum es gemacht hat, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Das war damals auch in den tollen, ja, no keyboard found, press any key to continue.
Ich mochte das.
Ich mochte dieses, dieses BIOS, diesen BIOS Style.
Heute hast du ja sogar Firmware-Update-Möglichkeiten in BIOS und Maus-Support.
Nicht, dass ich was dagegen habe, aber ich mochte diesen BIOS Style hier.
Ah.
Oh, wie lang ich keinen CD-Brenner mehr im Rechner habe.
Ich glaube, meine letzten drei Rechner, also sprich, das ist dann, also sagen wir mal seit 10 Jahren oder so, hatte kein Rechner.
Rechner von, nee, länger, länger, länger.
Chat, wann war euer letzter Rechner mit einem CD-Laufwerk, beziehungsweise einem Brenner?
Irgendwo habe ich das Ding noch.
Irgendwo habe ich noch meinen CD oder DVD-Brenner, ich weiß es gar nicht.
Irgendwo habe ich so einen Brenner noch rumfliegen, in irgendeiner Schublade.
2010, ja, so dürfte es bei mir auch gewesen sein in dem Dreh.
Okay.
CD-Brenner ist immer noch drin.
Okay, benutzt du den oder ist er einfach nur da?
This one is a good fit in that it was a solid option when it was new.
TDK's drives generally reviewed very well and were quite reliable.
The company made a number of models over the years and this one offers 48 times write, 16 times rewrite and 48 times...
Zum Thema selber brennen, kennt noch jemand die Zeiten, wo du deinen Rechner nicht benutzen durftest?
Weil es dann zu wenig...
...daten gab, um auf die CD zu schreiben und der Rohling kaputt war?
Kann sich noch jemand an diesen Shit erinnern?
Also, das erscheint euch jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen merkwürdig, aber das war damals so.
Wenn du ein Laufwerk hattest, das keine Buffer...
...ne, nicht Buffer Under Run oder sowas, ja, irgendwie sowas.
Buffer Under Run Protection hatte, also was quasi den Brennvorgang anhalten konnte.
Dann war der Rohling im Arsch, wenn der Brennvorgang nicht am Stück passieren konnte.
...Pretty compelling speeds for the era.
Some other removable media I wanted support for were floppies and zip disks.
100 MB chip drive.
Drives for which were of course ubiquitous at the time.
The hard drive was a tougher decision.
My first option was a 40 GB model from Samsung.
While that company is best known for its flash storage, ...
...it also produced mechanical hard drives for a number of years and...
...macht Samsung keine Festplatten mehr?
...its spinpoint line was generally a good value, ...
Ich hab glaub ich noch irgendwo ne Samsung-Festplatte rumliegen.
...though perhaps not the best in terms of performance.
The 2010s saw a lot of...
Und übrigens, hier.
Leute.
Jumper Pin Settings.
Das ist was, das vermiss ich ja aus dieser Zeit wirklich nicht.
Pin Settings.
Es gab...
Wart mal, was konntest du bei Pin Settings machen?
Konntest Master Slave Pin Settings machen?
Also das darf man ja heute nicht mehr sagen, aber damals hieß das so.
Master Slave Pin Settings und Cable Select gab's dann noch.
Wo ich mir sehr unsicher bin, was Cable Select eigentlich gemacht hat.
Und dann musstest du damals gucken, dass wenn du deine Festplatte und dein Brenner...
...am gleichen IDE-Kabel angeschlossen hast...
...dann musstest du gucken, in welcher Reihenfolge du die jumperst...
...weil...
...sonst hast du Probleme gekriegt. Teilweise, dass dein Brenner zu wenig Daten bekommen hat...
...und das dann den Rohling kaputt gemacht hat.
Und wenn du Maximum...
Das war echt ne Wissenschaft für sich, das anzuschließen und zu jumpern.
Limit Capacity, dass die sich nur als 32 klick meldet...
...weils ältere Rechner gab, die hatten halt Probleme mit...
...Festplatten über 32 klick.
ERQ-PIN für ISA-Karten, jo.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, mein Vater hatte damals ne Fritz-ISA...
...Fritz-Fritz-Card...
...Fritz-Box-Card-ISA-Dings.
Da musstest du Windows installieren, dann musstest du aufmachen den Rechner...
...den PIN-Schalter umstöpseln...
...auf den zugewiesenen Interrupt...
...und Interrupt, wie nennt man das? ID?
Das waren echt Frickelsachen.
Nee, das Jumpen vermiss ich auch wirklich nicht.
Ach, Seagate hat die gekauft.
Stopp, ich glaub IBM macht auch keine...
...keine Festplatten mehr.
Übrigens, so eine hatte ich auch jahrelang, aber...
...die hab ich nie benutzt.
Die hatte ich nur, weil mir die irgendjemand mal geschenkt hatte.
Ich hatte so ne 10 MB IBM Festplatte.
Das war ein riesen Ding, Alter.
Und...
...ich fand's irgendwie cool, dass ich so ne...
...das war so ne Festplatte...
...wenn du die aus'm Fenster geschmissen hast, die hat jemand abbekommen, der war tot.
Diese 10 MB IBM Festplatte, die war auch dreimal so hoch wie jetzt heutige Festplatten.
...with manufacturing hard drives.
And for quite a while, their offerings were considered high quality.
But in the 2000s, a large number of their desktop drives...
...started experiencing bad failure rates.
So bad that they garnered the nickname Death Star...
...and IBM had to settle a class action lawsuit.
It was such a big problem that IBM ended up selling...
...its hard drive division to Hitachi.
That company inherited quite the mess, but in the coming years...
...was able to turn things around and build a reputation...
...for producing very reliable drives.
But that doesn't mean this one would be.
The final and perhaps safest choice was this 80 GB model from Western Digital.
Die machen ja auch schon gefühlt seit den Indusauriern Festplatten.
It was sealed in a static bag, but the sticker indicated...
...it was refurbished, likely by the seller.
It probably would have been just fine, but I decided...
...a roll of the dice would be more interesting for this build...
...and actually went with the Dusk Star.
In a way, it was a no lose proposition.
If the drive worked, great.
If it failed, well, then it would just underscore...
...IBM's troubles at the time and make for a more...
Max Tor, stimmt. Ja, es gab früher mehr Festplattenhersteller als heute.
Es ist nicht mehr so viel übrig geblieben.
Es gab auch damals noch deutlich mehr Grafikkartenhersteller.
Du hattest nicht nur Voodoo noch, du hattest...
...ATI, Nvidia, ähm...
...wie hieß denn das?
Wie hieß denn die andere mit dieser Grafikkarte, die...
...schon richtig gut Texturen komprimieren konnte?
Ich hab's vergessen.
Dann hattest du...
...Matrox noch?
Wie hieß denn...
...Voodoo ist in die 3dfx.
Wie hieß denn diese Grafikkarte, die...
...irgendwie Savage 3D oder sowas?
Gab es sowas mal?
Ja, genau, von S3!
Das meine ich!
Ja, VIA gab es auch noch.
Die waren mal so ein Jahr lang...
...der übelste Geheimtipp, weil...
...die waren günstig...
...und die hatten so eine...
...die hatten so eine richtig advanced...
...Textur-Compression...
...was sie zeitweise mega...
...preis-leistungsmäßig...
...attraktiv gemacht hat.
Also für ein halbes Jahr.
Ihr wisst, ein halbes Jahr sind heute 5 Jahre.
Zwischen 1993...
...und 2003...
...ist es so viel wie heute 5 Jahre...
...was man austauschen muss...
...im Rechner.
Ich weiß noch, es gab damals für Serious Sam 1...
...wann kam das raus?
Auch schon ewig her.
2001, ja?
Es gab damals für Serious Sam 1...
...gab es...
...einen extra Patch...
...nur für diese Grafikkarten...
...und da konnte man dann...
...weil die so eine nice Textur-Kompression...
...hatten...
...konnte man dann...
...an die Wand ranlaufen...
...und der hat dann quasi nochmal...
...Details nachgeladen...
...für die Wand.
Das ist zum ersten Mal, dass man in einem Game...
...an eine Wand ranlaufen konnte...
...und dann von nahem auch Details...
...in dieser Textur hatte.
War richtig nice.
Nächste Generation hatten das natürlich...
...alle andere auch. Ja.
Die hatten alle Zeit hierher Grafikkarten gemacht, aber die...
...haben gaming-technisch...
...noch niemand jemals interessiert.
Damals war übrigens normal, dass man sich...
...einfach geschnitten hat bei allem, was man...
...in so einem Gehäuse macht.
Wenn man nicht aufgepasst hat.
Das war aber damals eigentlich...
...fast schon normal, dass so eine Front...
...von so einem Gehäuse recht bunt...
...bestückt war mit allen möglichen Farben.
Nee, nee, nee.
Das kenne ich nicht mal. Aber Phobis!
Alter Leute, Phobis ist der größte...
...Scheißland. Ich fange jetzt nicht wieder mit meiner...
...Phobis-Story an, aber die haben...
...bei mir verschissen. Aber zum Glück...
...gibt es Phobis auch nicht mehr.
Nee, die kenne ich nicht.
Beste.
Das war aber schon richtiges...
...High-End-Kabel hier.
Schöne Molex-Stecker. Die gibt's ja heute immer noch.
Die gibt's ja heute immer noch.
Wisst ihr, was ich nicht verstanden habe?
Was der Vorteil ist...
...von diesen komischen SATA-Strom-Steckern...
...versus die.
...warum man sich überhaupt dort was Neues ausgedacht hat.
Muss ja irgendeinen Sinn haben.
Ich meine, heutzutage...
...as der NVMe SSD ist...
...da ist das eh egal.
Die stöpselst den da in einen M2-Slot rein.
...da ist das eh egal. Die stöpselst den da in einen M2-Slot rein.
Also, normale SATA-Sachen musst du halt immer noch anschließen.
Mit diesem komischen SATA-Stromkabel.
Ich weiß einfach nicht, was der Vorteil von SATA-Stromkabel ist...
...versus...
Die Molex bekommst du nicht mehr raus, wenn du Pech hast.
Das stimmt schon!
Das rein-und ausstecken von diesen Molex-Dingern war schon nicht so geil.
Die haben sich ja auch öfters mal verbogen und verschoben und so.
Ja, du hast schon recht.
Tolle Stecker sind diese Molex-Dinger nicht gewesen.
Wir sind ein bisschen leise.
I only needed a couple of cards, and the first was something to replace the mediocre on-board
audio.
It's a Sound Blaster Live, a very common but also high-quality card from 1998 that was
still very relevant in the Pentium 4 era.
In addition to better audio connection options, it also adds a joystick port to this machine,
which motherboards had generally abandoned in fact.
Aber die lustigerweise an der Soundkarte dran waren, ich habe nie verstanden, warum
Soundkarten das gebraucht haben.
Guck mal, der hatte sogar schon einen digitalen Output, zwar noch kein Toslink, aber diese
andere Variante davon.
Einfach mal eine Grafikkarte mit einem Passivkühler drauf.
Schon eine GeForce, ja, das ist schon kein retro Rechner mehr.
.
Ja, und.
Kennt jemand noch dieses Ding?
Weiß jemand noch, was das für ein Anschluss ist?
Das braucht
heute kein Mensch mehr, aber
war damals ganz
cool.
S-Video, richtig, ja.
Konnte man Fernseher anschließen.
Da gab es dann so komische Kabel,
die gingen von dort in so einen
SCART-Stecker mit S-Video
Anschluss
und von dort dann an Fernseher.
Da konnte man den Fernseher anschließen an den Rechner.
Halt eigentlich
komplett unsinnig,
aber ich fand es damals mega nice,
dass man theoretisch einen Fernseher an den Rechner anschließen konnte.
Die SAP ist der
VGA-Stecker daneben.
Accessories included plastic.
Ja klar, TV-Karten hast du, also
man hat ja generell damals, wenn man
Multimedia-Zeug machen wollte,
also jetzt nicht bei der Rechner-Generation,
aber davor,
ohne TV-Karte hättest du gar nicht auf die Idee kommen müssen,
dort irgendwelche Videos abzuspielen.
Weil,
also gerade die Rechner-Generation davor,
da irgendwelche
MPEG-2-Videos zu decoden und so,
vergiss es.
...
Gab es jemals einen SCART-Ausgang
bei Grafikkarten? Ne, war doch sowas im Prinzip.
Du hast die Dinger immer,
du hast einen S-Video-Ausgang und den hast du
immer an so einen SCART-Stecker gestöpselt
für den Fernseher. Das war ja mit S-Video
quasi sowas.
...
Brock, wie viel
hast du noch?
Ich hab noch
was gewählt.
Wirklich?
Der Turbo-Knopf war ja nicht zum Turbo-Machen, sondern zum Gegenteil, um es langsamer zu machen.
Für olle Software und alte Spiele,
die eben noch an Takt raten.
Das erste Kommandos zum Beispiel,
falls es noch jemand kennt,
das war so ein Strategie-Game,
das war unspielbar auf neueren Rechner,
weil das eben nicht nach Timern ginge,
sondern nach CPU-Takt.
Und
da gab es eine Map,
Da ist so ein Schiff über den Fluss gefahren und bei Kommandos hast du dir immer so die Sichtkegel der Gegner angeguckt und das Schiff ist bei meinem neuen Rechner dann halt einfach den Fluss lang gefahren, wie als hättest du eine Sirene angehabt, weil das halt nach Takt gegangen ist und nicht nach irgendwelchen Timern.
Also deswegen gab es Turbo-Knöpfe, aber das war in dieser Ära eigentlich schon wieder out. In dieser Ära hatte eigentlich kaum Rechner noch Turbo-Knöpfe, das war eher noch ein bisschen davor.
...on the front of the tray. I powered the system on and it seemed to come to life. Except I never got any video. The monitor didn't wake up from sleep mode. I could toggle numlock on and off so the motherboard was responding, but it was clear there was a problem with that GeForce card.
When an AGP-Card is installed, the motherboard disables the onboard video, something I confirmed by hooking up the monitor to the built-in port and still...
Moment, das Ding hat es sogar schon.
Eine Onboard-Grafikkarte? Ja, dann ist das wirklich kein Retro-Bild.
Ich meine, das Ding hat Audio-Onboard, Netzwerk-Onboard, Grafikkarte-Onboard. Das musstest du früher alles einzeln einbauen, das gab's auf Mainboards nicht.
...not getting any output. That meant this card was simply dead. So much for doing a head-to-head comparison.
With the Radeon installed, I got much better results. No warnings about the CPU temperature either, so...
I think the new clock battery was indeed all it needed.
Yep, clock.
Up next was installing Windows XP, which meant...
Aldi-Rechner mit SCART, okay, das muss ich mir jetzt an...
Aldi von 2004, das war schon eines der, ja, Medion, das war noch eines der neueren Aldi-Rechner.
Die hat mit SCART ausge...
Alter, Aldi, man!
Das ist ja geil, das hab ich doch.
Das hab ich doch nie gesehen. Grafikkarte mit SCART-Ausgang, man.
Lul.
War gar kein schlechter Rechner für die damalige Zeit.
Was auch immer mit Aldi los ist.
Ja, Moment, jetzt hat er die Onboard-Grafikkarte, aber das bringt doch gar nichts.
Ja, das war damals immer abfuck, wenn das Ding gebootet ist.
Windows hatte standardmäßig keinen Treiber für die Netzwerkkarte dabei und so, das war schon kacke.
Da musstest du immer damals irgendwie selbst gebrannte CDs mit Treiber...
Ah, das war kacke, ja.
Oder von Disc.
Oh, das sieht aus wie so eine schöne Windows-Anwendung von 1995-Zeiten.
Was ist denn das, ein 15-Zoll-Bildschirm?
Was hat er denn da? Sieht ziemlich klein aus.
Sieht so aus, als könnte man ihn noch heben, ohne zusammenzubrechen.
Jadie Steele, Dankeschön.
Aha, CI-Treiber von Flobby beim Setup.
Du meinst, dass der irgendwie Festplatten und Sachen erkennt und weitere Laufwerke erkennt, ja?
Ja, das war noch im Windows-Setup so.
Drücken Sie jetzt F10 und inserten Sie die Treiber-Diskette.
It's a free utility that hosts a large repository of drives.
It's a free utility that hosts a large repository of drivers across many years worth of hardware,
für einige der anderen Komponenten, also habe ich es einfach gemacht.
Es wurde der Sounddriver installiert und... was?
Äh, Tomox sehe ich genauso.
MonkaS.
Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich nicht an Snappy Driver, das liegt wahrscheinlich an dem Kack-Driver, den Snappy Driver installiert hat.
Wenn der die Grafikkarte eingebaut hat,
dann kann es Crysis sp... aber nicht gut.
Nicht gut. Es kann auf jeden Fall nicht gut Crysis spielen.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, Far Cry 1 kam zu dieser Zeit raus.
Ich setzte die Resolution auf 800x600 und maxierte die Anwendungen, dann brachte ich die Demo ab.
Es hatte keine Probleme damit durchzugehen und postete ein Resultat.
Es war übrigens, by the way, meines Wissens nach das erste Game, was Runde torbögen konnte.
Das wird man sich in der heutigen Zeit gar nicht vorstellen können, aber...
Damals gingen in vielen 3D-Engines keine runden Flächen, außer halt gefaked als Textur mit Alpha-Transparenz und sowas.
Quake 3, Rounds, Arches heißt das, glaube ich, oder?
Ja.
Das, das, ähm...
In anderen Spielen konntest du es nur so machen.
Ja, du konntest halt so aus verschiedenen abgestuften Schritten, ging das.
Aber Quake 3 war das erste Game, was, wie man hier sieht, was richtig runde Torbögen und generell runde Objekte und sowas...
haben konnte in der Map.
Warte mal, ist 3DMark03 das, wo man mit dem Drache im Kreis fliegt?
Moment.
3DMarkDragonDemo?
Nee, das war 3DMark2000.
Ja.
Boah, bei der Grafik-Demo ging mir eine ab damals, Leute, sag ich euch.
Da ging mir richtig eine ab bei...
Bei dieser, bei dieser...
Ja, das...
Bei dieser Dragonflight-Demo.
Ja, das war das erste, ja.
Boah, da ging, da ging mir richtig eine ab drauf, ja.
Und man muss sich das mal angucken.
Es sieht schon nicht richtig...
Es sieht nicht gut aus, aber man kann es sich angucken, ja.
3D99?
Nee, denn...
An den, an den kann ich mich gar nicht mehr erinnern.
An den kann ich mich gar nicht mehr erinnern.
Naja, gucken wir weiter.
So, I left it set to its defaults and let it do its thing.
A score of 1012...
Nee, die, die, stimmt, die Radeon, ja, keine Ahnung.
Lag anscheinend doch nicht da dran.
...isn't awesome, but certainly not horrible.
Considering this Radeon 9200 was a budget card and sold for under $100 when new, it really wasn't a bad deal.
I wondered if perhaps the driver made much of an impact in this card's score, since I was using the built-in Microsoft one.
I updated it to a newer version from 2006, rebooted the machine, and confirmed everything looked good in Device Manager.
Rerunning 3DMark did produce an interesting result.
The score went up to 1034.
Was war's vorher?
That's not a huge improvement, of course, but it's hard to complain about getting extra performance.
Max, zeig mal ein UT99 Video, Facing Worlds.
Das sah auch gut aus, ja. Facing Worlds ist eines der ikonischsten Karten aus Unreal Tournament.
Das war das mit den zwei Türmen auf der einen und anderen Seite und dann diesen zwei kleinen Wegen in der Mitte, wo man langlaufen konnte.
Genau, ja.
Ja.
Wie wär's mal mit ein paar bewegten Bildern dabei?
Das war auch sehr optisch sehr gut für die damalige Zeit.
So was können die Leute, glaub ich, heute nicht allzu viel anfangen.
Es war schon wirklich auch eine coole Zeit.
Du hast bei den Spielen damals auch einfach gemerkt, die Leute haben das programmiert, was sie selbst feiern würden zum Spielen.
...for free.
By this time, I had managed to secure one more video card, so we'd still end up with a bit of a shit-up.
Ich will Unreal Tournament spielen.
...but this is an Nvidia GeForce Ti 4200 with 128 megabytes of video RAM.
Jetzt erstmal mit dem Redeemer im Nachkampf.
War der Redeemer dieses drehende, dieses komische drehende Messerding, wo du Leute im Nachkampf messern konntest?
Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt.
Die wollten ja ein neues Unreal Tournament entwickeln, aber dann war Fortnite so erfolgreich.
Aber ich glaube die Zeit von solchen Arena-Shootern wie das...
...ach, dann bring ich's durcheinander.
Dann bring ich's durcheinander.
Das ist vorbei. Das Interesse daran ist einfach nicht mehr da.
It was a mid-range card, but still pretty affordable at well under 200 bucks.
Like the Radeon before it, Windows already had drivers for this one, but I jumped straight to installing newer ones just for good measure.
Let's try Crysis again, because why not?
Yup, same video card warning and yup, crashes right away.
Ja, Crysis muss man nicht ausprobieren. Crysis kam irgendwie...
...jahre später raus als der PC gemacht wird. Zu der Zeit kam Far Cry 1 raus.
I can't say I'm surprised.
What was surprising though was Quake 3's numbers.
This card absolutely ripped through the demo and came back at over 200 frames per second.
More than twice as fast as the Radeon 9200.
I was excited. Would this translate into a similar improvement in 3D-Mark?
Nee, nee, aber trotzdem mehr.
The 4200 did score a lot better at 1478,
the 4200 did score a lot better at 1478,
but that's only about a 50% improvement...
aber nicht dreimal mehr.
...instead of the over 100% we saw in Quake 3.
Not that I'm complaining.
Since it also has a DVI output, it's clear that this Nvidia card is gonna be the one that'll stay in the machine.
That is for now.
The journey for this PC is far from over.
Since it's mine to keep, we'll be seeing more of it in future videos.
As it'll serve as a great platform for testing out other retro PC parts and accessories.
I like watching videos like these from old PCs.
I like watching videos like these from old PC builds.
Just because it reminds me of the time when I had one myself.
For me, it was technically one of the most exciting times.
Everything was new.
Absolutely exciting.
So fun.
It's already unlockable now!
Watch my videos inside the machine.
I definitely found the new software Australia when woo goes down the horse with my computer.
I like it.
gefällt, aber ich mag die Videos
nicht. Gaben
vor zwölf Jahren.
Ich habe zu wenige Tabs, finde ich
auch. Sollte noch ein bisschen mehr
sein.
Wir müssen unbedingt
noch... Was ist eigentlich mit
den Shorts hier gerade wieder los?
Ja, Chat, das habe ich auch gerade gedacht.
Ah, wieder so ein schönes G-Bait
Video. YouTube Shorts
sind komisch. Ja, ich weiß nicht. Wenn ich Shorts
gucken will, dann würde ich ja schon fast
lieber auf TikTok.
Wobei ich persönlich auch nicht gerne
auf TikTok gehe. Viele
YouTube Shorts sind auch
so rehashed TikTok
Videos. Du hast bei manchen YouTube Shorts sogar
noch das TikTok Video
unten in der Ecke.
Einfach
Copy-Pasta. Okay, Leute,
schön, dass ihr da gewesen seid. Spontan
auf Stream gewesen heute.
Wir sehen uns die Tage, vielleicht
morgen Abend schon. Morgen muss ich nach Frankfurt
fahren, erstmal
Keck-Business machen.
Und wir
sehen uns. Macht's gut. Bis dann.
C-E-R-C-U
Blblblblblbl